I tend to review anywhere between 2030
products a month and sometimes even
fewer than that like five and there's
just so much garbage out there so much
product that is no good and I wanted
people to know about it I also want
people to know what a product is good
I'm Kathleen Sammartino and I'm an
Amazon vine reviewer what is Amazon vine
Anacin vine is a program put up by
Amazon that allows people in the Amazon
community to select free products for
review and oh boy does Kathleen review a
lot of products
she's penned over 1500 reviews over the
years and is rated 234 on Amazon's top
reviewers list Kathleen who is a
self-described maximalist liked stuff
and a lot of the stuff in her home she's
reviewed on Amazon no not the cats
though she has reviewed plenty of their
beds and nail clippers she knows a thing
or two about Amazon reviews which can
make or break a product on America's
number-one shopping site but those star
ratings have become so important that
companies now will do just about
anything to get a four or five star
review including paying for them
[Music]
Kathleen showed me how vine works she
even walked me through the process of
reviewing a hair product she's been
trying so I just click on review this
product and I think this is pretty good
so I'm going to put the four star review
this dish in my hair and left my curls
very nice do you ever feel compelled to
give something a four or five star
review I absolutely do not feel
compelled to give something a four or
five star review if something is a bad
product it deserves to get a 1 a 2 star
review if you wait a while and you go
back to it it doesn't come out it starts
to bubble and you have to do it three or
four times before you get the stuff to
come out that's very frustrating I'm
ready to throw it out the wall Kathleen
takes her job seriously and doesn't
think her reviews are skewed
I don't feel uneasy taking
for free because it's not really free
and it's not free because of the fact
that I have to claim that those products
in taxes at the end of the year and as
1099 Brian reviews are marked on Amazon
to alert people to the fact that they
were reviewed in exchange for a free
product however many other reviews
including ones from verified purchasers
can be fake or incentivized recently
Amazon cracked down on these reviews
which offer positive 5 or four-star
reviews in exchange for money or free
products however the practice is still
very much happening via Facebook here's
how the illicit process works a buyer or
reviewer joins an Amazon reviews
Facebook group where sellers post about
free products save these Bluetooth
headphones the seller tells the reviewer
that in exchange for a five-star review
it will give that person the headphones
for free the reviewer buys the
headphones through Amazon receives it
writes the review post some photos and
rates at 5 stars the seller then sends
the reviewer the money via PayPal an
Amazon spokesperson said customers can
report suspicious reviews 24 hours a day
seven days a week and we investigate
each claim we suspend ban or pursue
legal action against these bad actors as
well as suppress all known inauthentic
reviews Facebook said in a statement we
takedown reported groups participating
in this type of activity
either way it's hard to tell what's real
in the reviews but there are a few
things Kathleen and others recommend you
do to spot the fakes there are a few
signs to me that a review might be fake
if you see postings that have several in
one day if you see reviews where it says
just amazing and they don't describe
anything about the product it's just a
one-liner also the people themselves if
you if you click on the person who
reviewed it and you see that they're
only giving five-star reviews or that's
their only review then that might be
suspicious as well you can also try
review Medicom or fake spot com these
sites rate reviews themselves you pasted
in the Amazon URL and it will return a
rating of the trustworthiness of the
views they actually removed the
untrustworthy reviews from the star
ratings and recalculate the average for
you I don't know whether it's the smell
of the box and the tissues itself but
they don't feel as lotion sure the vine
reviews might be useful to you and
people like Kathleen put a lot of effort
into them but as sad as this is to say
my best advice is to take all those star
ratings with a grain of salt if you
really want to do your part write a
review of your own Ricki you think five
stars
Riki I'm sort of allergic to you Ricki